This was a town.
Some kind of a
whaling station.
Totally abandoned now.
Look at this.
This is what I've been
looking for right here.
An iron bollard in the shore,
where Franklin tied
up their ships.
And this was the last anchorage
for the Franklin expedition
before they set off into
the Northwest Passage.
At that time, sailing over the
top of the world wouldn't have
been too different from the
idea of going to the moon.
You know, in terms of the
history of exploration,
there's nothing more epic.
You know, almost like a
Knights of the Round table
kind of thing to try to
make it through there.
It's wild to realize that
Franklin and his men were
walking all around here and
preparing for their voyage
into the Northwest Passage.
From here, the
ice gauntlet begins.
We just sailed
into a fog bank.
This is really really thick.
So I can see about a boat
length and the water is
filled with chunks of ice.
The radar shows the big stuff,
it shows the bergs,
but it doesn't show
the small stuff.
It doesn't show the growlers,
and the growlers could
tear the boat in half.
Crossing the maze of ice bergs
in Baffin Bay was the first
real test Franklin and his
men faced on their voyage
into the unknown.
This is part of the reason
why I wanted to sail to
King William Island, to be
faced with some of the same
decision points that
Franklin was 175 years ago.
It was the most modern, the
most well-equipped expedition
in the history of the
world at that point.
And they
disappeared without a trace.
The best way to describe kind
of what it's like out there is
I would call it a
savage wilderness.
Oh!
BEN: There it goes!
Oh man, look at it bouncing!
♪
MARK: We can see land!
Woo hoo!
I have to say, I really
like the place where
the land and sea meet.
Especially when there's
mountains involved.